here's a white guy that as a concern
let's gather this guy Oh what are we
really doing right now we're hopping
into king inner stinging thank you guys
for having me here today man just want
to say that NYX neck of the woods and I
got it King interesting for you guys
letting your girlfriend give you a
haircut all the barber shops are shut
down right now and I got to keep my
grooming on point so yeah I'm gonna let
her give me a mullet
she has no type of haircut experience at
all others should be able to handle this
before looks like I hit you guys back
with the final product
oh damn it [ __ ] lookin frosted she did a
great job
oh damn oh [ __ ]
drinking a beverage at a fresca is that
dudes great good-looking young men shoot
a great drama haircut Nick doing
anything you can to squeeze Wisconsin
[Laughter]
for two things Roe cheese and Steven
Avery don't cheese Steven Avery and Nick
and what's that guy and who is the big
running back that played it was calm
Ronde they have a history of great
running well I said but it's wrong it's
wrong so you definitely know try the new
guys the guys come out this year's a
[ __ ] he almost won a Heisman yeah you
know I'm talkin about ya know what I'm
gonna get torn apart cuz I'm blanking
right now but I got a lot going on back
here but yeah you don't as me what's the
noise everybody's got a name because Joe
Burrell won the [ __ ] high pieces of
[ __ ] nobody remembered some [ __ ]
demon forward trudging up there in the
mud playing [ __ ] behind behind all
giant white boys but I mean the Dallas
Cowboys was off at the line
John Deere he loaded up and I want to
say he did look it up and chin would
vouch for it if we could get any idea
which is
Jimmy cover-up it's hot enough to know
some house but Asian people or thinking
or feeling and then you cover up 60% of
your [ __ ] visual territory this
voiceless of draft ideas from going on
with Jim in how my glasses are getting
fogged up to know you're gonna die
you'll [ __ ] go back into the database
dude you gotta tighten up enough bro I'm
sitting over here with Marge Schott
[Music]
[Laughter]
Marge Schott side these are here [ __ ]
Crisco Sabo over here machine guard this
[ __ ] episode man dude my hilarious go
check him out if you get a change what's
this mess on Comedy Central comes
restful Comedy Central's YouTube page
yeah I watch it on his Facebook when he
puts the clips out there man well he's I
put him out but he needs the views yeah
gang can you're saying let your
girlfriend cut you here yeah be careful
though cuz all these [ __ ] who give
you that [ __ ] simple Jack mullet man
you know you got to be careful I want
let my girl touch my hair really mullets
are looking pretty
oh dude you got everyone doing moats now
man well I'll say this man and no that
little Cape down the back though just
getting a little long man what's coming
in now what are you gonna do with it oh
this is great I get to I know I don't
know what to do I'm not gonna let it go
long I don't know what to do what do you
mean then you've already said you
already yo you're not gonna let it go
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna keep
growing it like I'm a foot in a rock
band bro that [ __ ] dude
you say Clay Matthews huh really I don't
know what to do
get that [ __ ] decide what's this
quarantine is over I'm gonna switch it
up
well you could thin it I think just
keeping the table don't let the table
get too long and let that bat go long
man what's your son and never see you
with a [ __ ] long hair you're right
you know something like oh my dad looks
like a [ __ ] lesbian all the time
which was sunny be like I have some
pride and my father look at his [ __ ]
beautiful hair yeah you're right when
you're right you're right yeah look at
you right there doing East have long
hair bro cowboy is he where he leakin
that's our [ __ ] boy right there that
is our boy this is Brendan on the DL
bruh this is this is me if I ever got my
[ __ ] together the boy so jacked I wish I
had another 50 yeah get him holding the
dumbbells there you go dude dick root
bro oh look at Gold's Gym de croo I'll
tell you this though too as good-looking
as he is he's also like a legit trainer
to train for doom like he's a legit
trainer he trained her for doom four
days overdue Murray for doom Larry for
doom I don't know yeah no great name I
don't know this kid I went to school
with named Larry Verdun yeah he trained
up he was the youngest person in our
community ever to get scabies and that's
the senior citizen disease we looked at
up in xkv and he beat it uh I still
fighting I would say they're definitely
in overtime he's in the 12th round for a
long time to do it but yeah look at that
uh-uh oh yeah Oh scabies a little bug
dude I got a [ __ ] uh I'm a tick on me
from mountain biking man really think do
I going straight to my nut sack
what do you know what kind of biking you
doing he would eat mountain biking
really yeah come on it's gonna look what
I posted ma'am I mean I'm out there bro
you should get a bike and go with me
what I'm so lonely [ __ ] sport you go
through I mean all of them mountain
biking yeah it's right behind my house
dude you're gonna end up in full-contact
chest before this is all over I feel
like that'd be cool Wow look at this man
that's right by home behind my house
dude specialized hitter there and wish
your boy hello's on right did you unhook
the peloton or is that wow like a real
bike full go dude that [ __ ] is a work
out what's this in your mouth that's a
gel pack go you'll man a target that's I
get up that goddamn Mountain okay what
else you got Nick yeah let's get into
something here huh what was that guy
yeah you got to get that I think you
have to go full on the cup man you got
to get a good cut it's a good time to
maybe we should let fans vote on what
kinda I should do dang look at Brandon
[Laughter]
started GoFundMe there's a hundred
thousand dollars for you to rip your
dick off you saw some tits and give you
a rump like co-op with that and you got
a split the earning so it's only fifty
thousand for you and fifty for me I you
just get the sex
lipo on his ass a nose job will kill you
either
[Music]
nothing
[Music]